Okay Michael what's the answer.
>> Alright, so you kind of were walking us through
it, but basically if Yi and Ht agree, that means
they're both negative or they're both positive. They're equal
to each other. So when we multiply them together we
get one. One times whatever our alpha thing is,
some positive number is going to be positive. We're negating
that, so it's negative E to the negative something is
something between zero and one. Less than, less than one.
So, that's going to scale it down. So, it looks
like. And you know assuming that everything else goes ok
with, with the way that ,uh, the normalization happens right?
It seems like it could be depends on the normalization.
>> So by the way. That's a good point. The the x sub t. Is in fact, what ever
normalization constant you need at time T, in order
to make it all work out to be a distribution.
>> Correct. Then not going to, not going to change.
>> True.
>> But is some of them are correct and some of them incorrect, the ones
that are correct are going to decrease. And the
ones that are incorrect are going to increase.
>> That's right, so what's the answer to the quiz.
>> Depends.
>> That's true, it does. That's exactly the right answer.
It depends ,on what else is going on, you're correct. Now.
>> But I feel like it should
be decreases, like that's really, mainly what happens.
>> That's also fair. The answer is, if this one is correct,
that is they agree, and you disagree on at least some of
them, at least one, one other example, it will in fact decrease.
So I could ask a similar question, which is, well what happens
when they disagree? And at least one other example agrees. Then what happens?
>> Yeah, then they, then that should increase. Oh.
>> Right.
>> Oh. It's going to put more weight on the ones that it's getting wrong.
>> Exactly. And the ones that it's getting
wrong must be the ones that are harder. Or at least that's the underlying
idea. All right, Michael, so you got
it? So you understand what the equation's for?
>> Yeah, it look. It seemed really scary at first but it seems you know
marginally less scary now because all that it's
doing, it's doing it in a particular way.
I don't know why it's doing it in this particular way. But all it seems to
be doing is. The answers that it, it had, it was getting wrong... It puts more
weight on those and the ones that its
getting right, it puts less weight on those
and then you know, the loop goes around
again and it tries to make a new classifier.
>> Right, and since the ones that its getting wrong are getting more and
more weight but we are guaranteed or atleast we've assumed that we have a weak
learner that will always do better than
chance. On ,ah, any distribution, it means that
you'll always be able to output some learner that can get some of the ones
that you were getting wrong, right.